RENEE BROWN: Great.
Great.
Well, thank you.
It's great to see all of you.
And I want to thank
Google for the invitation.
I'm a fan of the
company and have
enjoyed working with all
of you through the years.
So it's good to have
faces with the company.
So thank you.
And so in talking to a couple of
the folks prior to this event,
the term intersectionality came
up, where I think all of you
are focusing on the
intersection of all
of our different
parts of our lives
and how that comes together.
So I'm probably
going to come back
to that as we talk through
some of the questions
and hopefully take
some of your questions.
But just by way of
introduction, to think
about all the
different hats I wear,
yes, I'm an executive
during most days.
I'm also a mom of a 15-year-old
and three-- well, two dogs
and one cat, a wife.
I serve on a national board.
I am the chair of the board of
my daughter's private school.
And I also am a
deacon at my church.
So you think about
all the intersections
of the LGBT family, your work
family, and then all the ways
we try to give back to the
different parts of our lives
that are important.
So hopefully we can
touch on a number
of those different areas.
And I probably have
other hats that I totally
forgot and whatnot.
But a little bit about my story.
I'm from South Louisiana.
So I am one of the
real Cajuns, even
though my last name doesn't show
it, my mother was a Primeaux.
And if you have any
Cajun jokes, it's
the Thibodeauxs,
Boudreauxs, Primeauxs, OK.
So I am I'm one of
those Cajun folks.
And so from a very
young age, I always
knew I was different
from a lot of folks.
So like many of you
probably, I took
upon myself to be like
perfect at everything,
be whatever, the
head of everything,
so that once people figured
out that I was different,
they would still kind
of maybe like me.
And so I took that path.
And I know a lot of people took
similar paths in their life.
My coming out story is kind
of a funny one in that my--
the story goes like this.
I was at college and my mother
called in a panic saying,
oh my god, Renee, your
sister is a lesbian.
But I've always known about you,
but, really, your sister too?
I was like, well,
great, thanks mom.
That was always very obvious.
So that's an important
part of my story.
My parents went two for
two and have two gay kids.
My sister runs the MCC
church for a little bit,
so she's the gay pope.
So you can look
up Rachelle Brown
and you'll recognize the
resemblance or at least
the voice.
But throughout my career,
you know being a lesbian,
as you know starting in banking,
it's a very conservative field.
And so I wasn't out there
in my first several roles.
And it really wasn't
until my partner
and I decided to start a family
that the whole coming out
process started in earnest,
because if you're pregnant
and you're coming out, you have
to come out, because you have
to explain your relationship.
And so that process really
was a real turning point,
not only in my personal
life in starting a family,
but also in my
professional life.
And a lot of people have said,
well, does having a child
and coming out, does
it harm your career?
In my situation, I
left on maternity leave
as a person on the brand team
at Wachovia, and came back,
and they immediately said you're
the head of brand management,
you're a senior vice
president, it starts now.
And it's like, OK, I didn't
interview for anything.
I think that's against
a lot of HR policies.
But you know, I started
and just jumped right in.
So my experience was a very
positive one on that front.
But you know, through
my career, I've
been in financial services
marketing for a very long time
and I've served in a
lot of different roles.
I've had a chance to do
a lot of different things
across financial services.
And I think a part of
that is because I'm
really open to taking on new
challenges and new experiences.
And so as we go through
some of these questions,
I hope to share some
of that, because I
think the intersections
of all of our experiences
make us a better worker
for whatever company
we're serving at the time.
So anyway, that's just a
little bit more about my story.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
Thank you.
And could you tell
us a little bit more
about the leadership
role that you're in now?
What are you tasked with
and what kind of team
do you oversee?
And just to build
on your last point,
we'd also love to hear
about some of the challenges
that you're most excited
about approaching
in your current role.
RENEE BROWN: Absolutely.
So I'm running marketing
for the retail side of TIAA.
And so for folks not
familiar with TIAA,
it's a 100-year-old company
that's known for retirement
and helping universities
and not-for-profits
in their retirement space.
And we just launched
into retail.
And so it's a very young
part of the company.
It's really a startup
with the exception
we do have an advisor
force, which is very small,
about 850 advisors.
The last company I left
had 15,000 advisors,
so a very different scale and
scope, and a very different way
of going to business.
But we just purchased a bank.
And so we're
integrating that bank
over the next several weeks.
The goal, and what my
team is responsible for,
is figuring out how do we
go to market differently.
We're a not-for-profit
organization.
And how do we go up against
the B of A, Merrill, Chase,
others in the financial
services industry like Fidelity,
and show up differently and
show our not-for-profit heritage
and really try to
disrupt the marketplace?
And so that's the challenge
I'm taking on now.
I have a small team.
I haven't counted.
I don't know how many people,
probably about 50 people
on the team now.
And it's really
exciting, because--
so I was with Wachovia
Wells for 20 years.
And in that whole process,
even in brand management,
we were constantly trying to say
how is this company different.
Well, we're on
every street corner.
With the Wells example,
we have ponies.
We can give out plush
ponies to people.
Yes, that's a thing.
But there wasn't anything
like heart and soul,
whereas TIAA has a soul.
And we're trying to
uncover that, and show
this really cool
company, and show how
it's different in the market.
So it sounds like
it might be easy,
but it's going to
be a challenge just
with a lot of different
structures we have.
So yeah, we met
with our Google team
a little earlier to talk
a little bit about that.
And so I'm excited
about the opportunity.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
And you touched on
this a little bit
about sort of your promotion
during your maternity leave,
but what path did you take
to your current role at TIAA
and your path to
this previous role?
RENEE BROWN: Gosh, I think--
you know, some people actually
had plans for their career
and I definitely didn't.
The only thing consistent
with my journey
is that I always took on a
job no one else wanted to do.
And that has been
kind of my hallmark.
And I discover that
if you raise your hand
and do something
no one else wants
to do that you're beloved
by the management,
because it's typically something
that's hairy, complicated,
political, and people
don't know the answer.
And even if you can get in
and move it just a little bit,
people love you and you're
kind of marked with that.
So I started my career on
the regular banking side
doing tons of integrations
in New Orleans for Hibernia
Bank, which was
bought by Capital One,
so that's how long ago that was.
But it was fun being single and
26 living near Bourbon Street.
And then with Wachovia, I was
on the small business side.
And that was really
cool, because I
got to learn how
business bankers go in
and help companies.
And I found that to
be very fascinating.
And then when First
Union bought Wachovia,
I moved into brand management.
And that was a great
learning, a great ability
to kind of step back and say,
how can a company be different
but not just how it's expressed,
but how people actually
behave at the company.
And that's where
magic can happen
with different institutions.
But I quickly realized that
everyone's a brand expert.
I don't know if
you all know that.
And I got really
burned out with some
of the components of branding.
And so no one at
the company wanted
to support the
financial advisors,
because they are known
as cowboys, and cowgirls,
and mean people.
And I'm like, I'll take that on.
So I went and got my series 7.
And I'm like, OK, I'm going
to do this whole brokerage
thing, and retirement
asset management.
I did that for seven
years pre and post-merger
with Wells Fargo.
And so that was
really great learning.
Did the AG Edwards integration.
That was the biggest brokerage
integration in history.
It was awesome.
Learned so much.
And then after that, I raised my
hand for another problem, which
was Wells Fargo's social
media was a disaster.
And so the board was kind of
standing on the management
and said, you guys
have to centralize
this, which the company
didn't centralize anything
at the time.
So I was the person who
brought social media together.
And that was really fun.
I kind of got out of
marketing for those few years,
because, as you know,
standing up a social media
platform for a
company that large,
you're dealing with HR
issues, because employees
love posting things that
they should not post, and PR.
And it was a lot less
marketing than it
was some of the managing
kinds of things.
And so the last
role I had at Wells
was actually in
the community bank.
And all of you know
where that is right now,
so I'm happy to be at TIAA.
So you know, I mean each of
those twists and turns involved
some component of no
one wanted to touch it.
Like my last role,
community banking,
no one wanted to touch
that, because everyone
knew there were
problems and things
were getting ready to blow up.
And that's what happened.
So, yeah.
Does that help?
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
Just taking a step
even further back,
what was the first
job that you ever had,
and did you imagine in that job
that you would find yourself
here in this current role?
RENEE BROWN: Mm-mm.
I think all of you would say
the same thing, I would assume.
I started my first
job at the age of 16
on my birthday at 6:00 AM.
I was a radio announcer.
And the reason is my sister
was a radio announcer
and we sound a lot alike.
And so that's how
I got my first job,
because I sound like my sister.
But she continued in radio
for a lot longer than I did.
But that was really great.
I learned a lot.
I did radio announcing
from that age into college.
And I was actually a traffic
reporter in Baton Rouge
where there's awful traffic.
If you all have ever
been through there,
you know, but I actually flew
in the airplane every morning,
every night.
And I was uptown Renee
Brown for a long time
through graduate school.
And every job I ever did--
and during college,
I took any job
I could working my
way through college.
I was a receptionist for
an architectural firm.
I worked at the library.
You name it just to get money,
because, believe it or not,
being a radio announcer
isn't very lucrative.
But what I learned announcing
traffic in particular
is you have 30 seconds.
And you know, sometimes you'd
have two interstates shut down.
You had all this stuff to
say and you had 30 seconds
to get it done.
And how did that translate
to my later jobs?
I mean some of my
roles, and you have all
experienced that, you go
in for a big presentation
with somebody and they
want the 30 second version.
And so to have that
experience of saying,
OK, I have 30 seconds.
What are the three things
I can say in 30 seconds?
And believe it or not,
that has been very helpful
for my career.
So even though knowing
media and that side of media
has been helpful for
my marketing career,
that's the piece that probably
was the biggest learning for me
as a younger person growing up.
But I did also
learn a lot in radio
of exactly what not to do
from an HR sexual harassment
standpoint.
Very different indeed.
SPEAKER 1: And then
pivoting towards--
again, you're an out
LGBTQ identifying woman.
How do you feel like identifying
as an LGBTQ woman, or generally
more broader as a woman,
has positively or negatively
affected your career
and your growth?
RENEE BROWN: You know,
I think one thing that's
true across LGBT and
other diverse segments
is I think people gain
more empathy growing up
when you are the
subordinated group
for the majority of your
upbringing or your lifetime.
And so understanding
what it feels
like to be not in
the dominant group
and having empathy and
tracking, because I
used to pay attention a lot to
people's emotions in the room.
I think some of you
probably have experienced
that too to kind of
sense when things
are going in the wrong
direction and redirect them.
And so I think that empathy
is critical for anybody
who is a leader of people
to really understand
how to read a situation and
use that level of empathy,
and also knowing how to
be both aware when you're
in the dominant group and how do
you help people that aren't is
an awareness level that a
lot of people don't have.
Because usually when
you're in a dominant group,
and you have power and
authority and all that stuff,
you're unaware of it.
And the best place to
look at this is airport.
We were kidding
around about airports.
It's so fun when like
something happens
and everyone gets
messed up with a flight.
It's fun to watch the super
privileged people freak out
and just lose their mind because
they're being inconvenienced.
And that's a sure
example of people
who are very unaware that
they have all this privilege.
And once they're put in
a position without it,
they don't even know how to
deal with the world around them.
And so I think, for me,
being an LGBT leader
and a female leader,
I kind of try
to carry all that background
of when I wasn't an executive,
and I didn't have the
power or authority,
and how do I use
that for good as I've
moved through my career.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
Do you recall a moment in
your career or in your life
when you realize that
being visibly out
would actually be an asset to
you, either in your career,
or in your work with
nonprofits on boards, et Cetera
RENEE BROWN: Yeah.
You know, I think probably
the moment when-- you know,
for a long time I was executive
sponsor of LGBT groups
at Wachovia and then at Wells.
And when we transitioned
over to Wells,
there was a lot of conversation.
And no one really
wanted to go talk
to the head of compensation
around the whole gross up.
This was before domestic--
when we had domestic partner
benefits and you needed to gross
up people's taxes on health
care for their partners.
And that was the moment where
I realized I had access,
I knew the head of HR, I knew
this guy in compensation,
and the people in the ERG
didn't have that access.
And it's like, OK,
this is a win-win,
because I can go knock on
a door, and open a door,
and have a conversation
that's different,
because we're working with one
another on different things,
not just this.
And so that's a real asset.
And what I have found
through the years
is a lot of times there
are LGBT folks who
are not out at higher levels.
And that's a real shame, because
they're missing an opportunity.
And you know, other
diverse groups
aren't as supportive
one to another.
And that's a shame,
because that's
where we can really have a
voice and be able to have
conversations differently.
So that's how I've
seen it as an asset is
to open doors for others
who weren't able to do that.
SPEAKER 1: Have you
ever experienced
adversity, and kind
of the converse side,
as a result of
being out at work?
And would you be OK sharing
one of those stories with us?
RENEE BROWN: Sure.
And this is probably
less at work.
It's probably more a side
effect of being so comfortable
at the office.
And so this situation happened.
I don't know what
the year was, but I
was getting in a taxi in St.
Louis heading to the airport.
You know, the AG
Edwards, now Wells Fargo,
Securities' headquarters
is in St. Louis.
And so get in the taxi, you know
normal chit chat conversation
with the driver,
and he said, OK, so
what does your husband do?
I said, I don't have a husband.
I have a wife.
And she stays home
with our child.
And he left the interstate
and went someplace
that I knew wasn't on
the way to the airport.
So I realized, great, I
just totally got some guy.
And he's going to go chop me
up in little bits and pieces.
And so I immediately
got on the phone with HR
and I was just chatting with my
HR partner, because I'm like,
I'm going to be on the
phone with somebody
while whatever happens happens.
And he wound up
driving through a park
and then getting back on track.
But he was very--
he did not appreciate the fact
that I was very out and honest
about my personal situation.
And so that was like
a lesson for me.
Like within the walls
of your workplace,
you can be very honest, and
sometimes in other places
it's good to say,
you know, whatever,
not answer the question.
But yeah, that was one
big learning for me
that got me a
little bit worried.
SPEAKER 1: I can
definitely say I've
had similar Uber experiences.
How do you and your wife balance
your career and your family?
RENEE BROWN: You know, I don't
know if there ever really
is work/life balance.
A lot of people
ask that question.
And I think there's
times of throttling up
where you're completely
out of balance
and it's needed at whatever
time that is in your career.
I mean, if you fundamentally
change jobs or change
companies, it's not
like you're going
to have a whole lot
of work life balance.
And so I think it's
important just to name that.
But you can't
always have the out
of balance kind of situation.
And it's not always throttling
up and spending 20 hours a day.
And so we have routines,
like many others,
you know whether it's the
Sunday evening dinners,
or another work/life
balance thing is actually
turning the phone off.
I do stop in the evenings
and have some quiet time,
particularly as my
daughter has gotten older.
Now she's 15.
She's taller than me.
She's smarter than
me, literally.
Her SAT score is way better than
mine was as a senior already.
But it's harder to have
a teen talk to you.
And so we have to really
make time and have quiet time
as a family in the
evenings to actually
have a conversation happen.
And then the other piece
is we do take vacations.
And so I was telling
them I'm heading out
next Wednesday, which
is a little stressful,
but we're going to go
on a two week vacation.
It's critical to actually
get some downtime,
because it's easy to let
both relationship and family
kind of fall apart with
all the things pulling
at you from your work.
And so we try not
to have that happen.
I don't know if we're
successful all the time though.
SPEAKER 1: No one's perfect.
RENEE BROWN: No.
SPEAKER 1: And you had
mentioned your sister
and also that you serve as
a deacon for your church.
How does religion
come into your life,
and especially since it can
oftentimes be perceived as,
by members of the
LGBTQ community,
as being at times at odds
with being LGBTQ identified
and being open
about it, so I would
love to hear how you address
that with your own identity
and with your own faith.
RENEE BROWN: Yeah.
I thought that would
be an interesting area.
And I don't know if that's
something all of you
have seen at Google.
But with other companies
and other ERGS,
working with Out and
Equal, for example,
it's interesting that, as
companies expand and get
faith ERGs, that
people see that there'd
be a conflict between a
faith employee resource
group and an LGBT resource
group, or LGBT and military.
It's all kinds of
interesting thoughts
around different
diverse groups and where
they might agree or disagree.
And I have a very different
perspective on it,
particularly in the
last year and a half
as we've seen all diverse
groups attacked equally
by the administration, by
parts of the media where,
if you're a person
with disabilities,
somebody is picking on you,
you're a person of color, LGBT,
you name it.
Everyone seems to
be under attack.
And so as we think about all
these different diverse groups,
I think we as a collective
need to figure out
how to work together and really
help the cause of anybody who's
diverse.
And so I think that's critical.
And I don't think
we've figured it out.
I mean, if you think of all the
diverse groups in the country,
if we all actually
got together, we
would have a huge voice against
what's happening in our society
right now.
And folks aren't doing that.
And I think it's an opportunity.
And with religion
specifically, that's
where I've had the most dialogue
across difference with folks,
because I welcome people
having a conversation who
might feel like their
religion says that they
can't support LGBT folks.
And so those have been
difficult conversations.
But everyone has helped move
forward just a little bit.
My upbringing-- I
spent three days a week
in a church that really thought
LGBT folks were going to hell
and said it frequently.
So I was damaged by my early
childhood religious experience.
And so it wasn't until
we started a family
and my wife made
me go to church,
and we shopped for a
church and found one.
And it took years of
healing, honestly,
to be in a church
that basically feels
the same way Pope Francis
feels is that all of us
are made in God's image
and loved equally.
And it takes a long time to
heal from some of the scars
if you've heard other
tapes in your head
throughout your upbringing.
And so I just wanted to name
that, and then my sister
being a minister, and a
reverend, and leading a church.
I think it's an
important thing to name,
because I know
other LGBT folks who
left any semblance of
faith out of their lives
for any number of reasons.
You know, pride parades, people
holler and screaming at you,
things like that.
It can be very disconcerting.
But you know,
times have changed.
And I think it's
time for us to have
good dialogue and a
real understanding
of different areas
of faith, and open up
dialogue between an LGBTQ
ERG, and a faith ERG,
and be visible in that, because
to say I'm a lesbian Christian,
I'm very comfortable
saying that now.
Now.
Years ago I wasn't for
a number of reasons.
But I just think that's
an important dialogue
that a lot of companies aren't
having that conversation.
SPEAKER 1: It sounds like also,
based on your earlier coming
out story, that it's something
your sister also deals
with in her faith as well.
RENEE BROWN: Yeah.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: And you
also touched on this
in terms of working together
as different minority groups.
But how do you--
it's easy to talk them out
in practice or in theory
of how do different employee
resource groups work together,
how do different minority
groups work together,
and you know their
strength together
is greater than the sum
of each individual parts.
But how does that work?
And how can employee resource
groups in different minority
groups work together effectively
to advocate for one another?
How do you see that working?
RENEE BROWN: Yeah.
I think having a
common set of goals
is probably the most
critical component.
We've had so many
events in society
of late that could
be rallying cries
for groups of different ERGs to
come together and do an event
or have some kind of activity
that could be meaningful.
You know, you think
of Charlottesville.
And what are the
LGBTQ ERNs doing when
situations like that happen?
And I think that's
the consciousness that
needs to come up.
I've seen some
companies pool members
of each of the diverse ERGs
and have dialogue across those,
like the Asian-American group
to include parts of the world
that someone might think a
military person might not
want to sit by them, or you know
have an LGBTQ military veteran
have a conversation with
somebody in a faith group.
You know, all of those
kind of mixing and matching
this diverse-- it kind
of creates a tension.
And so having panels
like that is something
that I would recommend.
And then with my work
with Out and Equal,
we're doing a lot of
focus on companies
who are international in
scope, because, as you know,
as you move out of the US, there
are a lot of countries where,
if you move different employees
around and they aren't out,
it can be very
challenging for them
in countries where you could
get killed for being LGBT.
And so we're working through
trying to help give resources
to institutions on
how do you facilitate
those kinds of
interactions, and how do you
work in a country
like India that
has laws that prohibit a lot
of openness around people's
LGBTQ orientation.
So that's an emerging space
that isn't going to change,
because our world keeps
getting smaller and smaller.
And those kinds of issues
will continue to come up.
And also the other
thing I'd name
that is a growing space is
our next generation, which I'm
sure all of you
have plenty of Gen Z
here at the Google headquarters.
You know, when we think
about that generation,
the gender fluidity, and
issues at work around that,
and the lack of understanding
of senior leaders of most
companies around that
space is really critical.
I mean, I've gotten some
questions that I didn't even
know the answer to,
which is my own learning
that I have to keep growing
and learning in that space.
So anyway, those are all
areas that I know Out
and Equal's focused on.
And a lot of
companies are trying
to make sure there's education
and understanding across that.
SPEAKER 1: And actually touching
on the Out and Equal piece
again, how does your
position as an executive
affect how you
approach organizations
like Out and Equal,
your service there,
and other causes
that you support?
RENEE BROWN: Yeah.
You know I have served on
the board of the Red Cross
for years.
And part of the reason
for that is just
being from South Louisiana
and having hurricanes
in the backyard every
weekend just about,
and seeing the fact that that
organization is always there
for people no matter what.
And the Red Cross and Red
Crescent internationally
is an amazing organization.
And I just kind of--
I share values with
that organization.
I moved from that group
over to Out and Equal.
And it's been a really
great learning for me.
And one of the things
I have appreciated
is just the ability
to meet people
across industries who
are making a difference
in their organizations and
helping, not only LGBTQ causes,
but a lot of others.
And so that's been
invaluable for me.
And in fact, that
organization, Out and Equal,
just had a new CEO come
in, really exciting.
We're going to be having a
strategic off-site in Disney
in a month.
And I'm looking forward to that.
I think we're going
to blaze a new path,
because Out and Equal's
known for their summit, which
is going to be in
Seattle in October.
But also we have to
do more webinars.
We have a lot more education.
There's a lot more that
we have to do and catch up
with the times,
because you guys know
in-person summits are really
hard for people to get to.
Of course, the
Gaygglers have always
been a loud group at summits.
I will give you that.
[INAUDIBLE]
And so, anyway-- so yeah.
I find board work, whether
I helped our church
with long range
planning or I'm now
leading the board of
my daughter's school
as I mentioned, I find
that a great distraction
and a great learning.
So oftentimes
when-- so I've been
in marketing a million years.
And it's not that I'm
not learning in the role,
but I don't get to get
out of that box as often.
So right now our school
is buying property,
and going through
all the rezoning,
and doing all kinds of
things that it's like, I
don't have a chance to do that.
So I find it stimulating
and interesting.
And also, it helps
to put a face,
with that group in
particular, a face
to the LGBT world in a
different way for those parents
of other kids.
And I think we have to do that.
We have to be out
in our communities
and serving in roles that
might not be as expected.
And I think it just
helps people know
it's like, OK, me and my wife,
we have kind of the same life
that all of the other parents
around the table have.
We're doing the
best we can trying
to deal with all the things
that you face with a teenager,
and comparing notes on
does this work or not,
going through the
circle of life.
And to share that
with people who
are not in our core LGBTQ
community is critical.
And I learn a lot
from the process.
SPEAKER 1: And I know that was
the end of my formal questions
here.
But I know we had some
questions on the Dory.
And I think one of
them in particular,
just to touch back on a
comment that you made earlier,
was about advice
that you would give
to young people in your career.
And you had mentioned that,
specifically in your career,
you always found it to
be very helpful to take
on that big, hairy role that
no one wanted to take on.
So I'd love to hear a little
bit more about sort of the--
obviously, there's
a huge opportunity
that comes with taking
on something that's
challenging and potentially
has high visibility,
but also a lot of risk
associated with that.
So I would love to
hear a little bit more
about how you've also
balanced the risk associated
with taking some of those
challenging roles along
with the opportunity.
RENEE BROWN: Yeah.
And probably taking on
social media at Wells
was probably the
highest stakes one.
The ones prior to
that were more,
OK, it's a gap that
needs to be filled
and I'm going to
go fill that gap.
But in that role, it
was really, really clear
that the company was
on the wrong path.
And there were huge
issues going on
that if any auditor
would come in,
it would be a flaming disaster.
In fact, our internal
audit showed up two weeks
after I started and
freaked me out completely.
So instead of resisting
them, I just brought them in
and said, OK, here's
everything I've seen.
We have no exit strategies.
We have no strategies
for any platform.
We have no controls,
no governance.
It was just, you name it.
Everything that would
freak somebody out.
And I took it as an
opportunity to say, audit,
can you help me put this
together in the right way?
And they did.
And they were fabulous.
And they didn't ding me
too badly on that survey.
But it was a huge risk.
And the way I balanced that
is as I took the role on,
I went and talked to several
executives at the company.
And I said, look, a lot of
people see this as play time
or not serious or
something to be controlled.
And you guys know social
media can't be controlled.
And that was part
of my challenge,
is talking to the
baby boomers who
are trying to control
the younger generation.
And it was so clear that
you can't control it.
And it's so clear
also in our society,
things can be right and
wrong at the same time,
depending on what perspective
you take on an issue.
And so translating that was
a critical part of my role.
But I talked to a
lot of executives
and just said, how do
I take on this effort?
And the resounding feedback that
I got is use risk as the key.
Because if you can outline
all the risks associated
with what's happening
and how to mitigate them,
they're going to give
you a blank check.
And that's exactly
what happened.
The company said, OK,
what number do you need?
And so we opened command
centers on both coasts
and set up the entire system
the way it should be set up.
And the really unfortunate
thing about that
is the command centers
weren't used until everyone
found out about sales practices
issues at the company.
And so that was when the command
centers really came into use.
But I'm glad at least I was
there to put that together
for the company.
I would have preferred
the company use those
for something really
positive, as opposed
to a huge ding for the
brand that they may never
recover from now.
But that was the
biggest risk in taking
on something that was hairy.
And I think getting the counsel
of many different people
and being clear on
what is the role,
and what are the
truths and non-truths,
and how do they
all come together.
And how then can you
articulate it to the audiences
where it makes
sense, whether that's
the board of directors
or the employee
who thinks talking about smoking
joints during office hours
is a good idea.
We had a lot of that.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Well, that's
definitely an interesting note
to end on for the
formal questions.
But I wanted to open it up
before we go the Dory to anyone
in the room who would
have a question.
Or we can switch it over.
AUDIENCE: One of the
questions I have is--
I really admire the
sense of responsibility,
it seems, that you have
as identifying as LGBTQ
and taking that on.
And I'd be curious to know
if there was sort of a moment
where you felt
that responsibility
or if it maybe was more
equated to maturity,
or where during your life or
career that you said, wow,
I really need to make
sure that I use my voice.
RENEE BROWN: Yeah.
Thank you for the question.
And I think I would go
back to when I supported
that large brokerage firm.
And so anybody knowing Wall
Street brokerage firms,
they're mainly male
and typically 56.
I'm sure that age is higher now.
And pretty much straight with
only very few exceptions.
And so it was in that role
that I realized I really
need to show up not
only as a female leader,
but also be authentic.
And one of the ways that
that was made easy for me,
that I should name, is that
having a kid is an equalizing
force to where you can really
connect with somebody if they
also have kids and just
talk about their children
and that situation.
You don't have to name the
family structure or anything,
but it just makes a common--
you have some
common ground there
that I found was a
really important platform
that then I could use to
explain the differences
between our families when
there were differences.
I mean, now, thank goodness,
there are so many different
things, where I'm
actually married,
as opposed to when we weren't.
And the financial
situations my family
had were very different from the
people I would be talking to.
And sometimes I had a chance
to do that kind of education,
you know, that moment.
But it was then when
I realized, OK, I
can create a common ground with
people who probably had never
talked to a lesbian
leader before, honestly,
or saw them in any
way where there
was some kind of common ground.
And that's where it cemented for
me that I need to be a leader
and show up in the right ways.
And then also, as you start
getting older in your career,
you realize people younger than
you are actually watching you.
And so I feel responsibility
around that, where it's like,
I need to handle myself
in a way that is something
people would want to follow.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you again so much
for coming and talking today.
My question for
you is how do you
think that the folks
running the LGBT ERGs
can best engage with more
senior folks, especially given
that time is frequently
difficult to come
by as folks get more and
more senior in their career?
RENEE BROWN: Yeah.
That's a great question.
And one of the things
that really surprised me
when I joined TIAA last year,
we had a panel, LGBT panel.
And I think it was
on Coming Out Day.
It was October 11 last year.
And what really surprised
me is as the panel started,
in walked the entire
executive committee,
our CEO and all of his
direct reports except
for maybe two who
couldn't make it.
And that was the first
time in any of the time
I've done this,
in the two decades
I've been playing
around with this stuff,
that the entire executive
committee joined an LGBT event.
And that just floored me.
And it was really impactful.
It made me realize
TIAA really walks
the talk around the
importance of all of the ERGs
because they would do that with
other employee resource groups.
And so I don't think that
is unusual for the company,
but I think that's something
where you guys should
ask leadership to
actually join and be
visible in different events
because that goes a long way.
Certain folks might show up
for some events and not others.
It tells a story about
who's not present.
So that would be one
thing, is making sure
that the leadership is present,
but finding the right network.
So I'm sure within--
how many employees do
you guys have at Google?
AUDIENCE: 80,000 or
something like that.
RENEE BROWN: Oh, really?
OK, I thought it was
a little bit bigger.
If you think about the
entire organization, have you
guys mapped out where
the rising leaders are,
and really making sure
that they have a voice
and are using their voice
both for LGBT and otherwise.
That's important.
And with talent review--
I'm sure your company
does talent reviews, where
people go through and say
who's the upcoming talent.
And they always flag whether
they are in a diverse group.
You've got to advocate to
have a rainbow on there.
And so I'm doing that
now at our company.
It's complicated
because there are
some legal issues around
it, but if you just
are showing if
somebody is a female
and whether they're a person
of color, that's great,
but we also need to have
the LGBT thing there.
Because that's one of the
reasons people don't come out.
They don't see it
as an advantage
as they're moving
up in their career.
So advocating as an ERG
to have talent reviews
include people who are
openly willing to share that.
Because to me, I
hired a friend of mine
who's an
African-American gay man.
I'm like, that's a twofer.
We need to get double
bonus points for that.
And so anyway, advocating
for that at the company
is important because
every diverse group
that somebody has within
them, every additional one,
is more experience around
things that all of us
need to learn from.
So those are some of
the thoughts I have.
But engaging your senior
leadership to attend events
is a very outward display of
support that I would recommend.
AUDIENCE: In the vein of
this question that you just
answered, how do you think that
your own rise over the years
have affected your ability to
do what you just said, advocate
and whatnot?
RENEE BROWN: I find that I've
been very lucky in my career
as I've moved up.
But honestly, I think a lot
of it is a lot of hard work,
just like all of you have
experienced, that you have
to do a ton of
hard work and a ton
of caring for people, and
then doors are open for you.
But having a voice on
LGBT, I'll tell you,
I've had many situations
where I've come really
close to not saying anything.
Being the person in the
room saying excuse me,
you just use language that
really isn't appropriate
and can be offensive to people.
That's important.
But one thing I
would tell you is,
it was about midway
through my career
that I realized I have less
a voice on LGBTQ matters
than I do watching out
for my people of color
because I'm not a
person of color.
I have more of a voice
going after something
if I see an issue around
that because I have nothing
to gain in it.
Whereas some people
will see, well, that's
just the angry lesbian
or the angry gay man
fussing about something.
So that's why I point out,
how do we help other ERGs?
How can we give voice to
people who don't have voices?
And I think that's
where power comes in.
So I try to go beyond being
an LGBT leader to being,
I'm a leader trying
to help diversity
at the company and inclusion,
which is super critical.
Because when you get to
the point of inclusion,
it goes to a lot of things
that a lot of companies
don't talk about.
It gets to how people look.
It gets to their social
class and social status.
It gets to weight.
It gets to-- let's
start naming things
that cause people to
be in the out group.
That area of
inclusion is something
that all of us who understand or
have ever been on the receiving
end of being excluded
for something,
we all have to be a voice
to make sure everyone
is included in things.
Because that's how
companies do a better job,
teams do a better job.
So I'd say yes, I've
had a voice with LGBT.
But I've seen more power helping
other groups that I'm not
a member of every day.
AUDIENCE: But you
have, over the years,
more recently, do
you feel like you
were more or less able to
do that because of the roles
that you take now?
RENEE BROWN: More able.
Yeah.
I mean, the more resources you
have, the more budget you have,
it's really great.
Like so yeah, I
can write a check.
AUDIENCE: But time
is not an issue?
RENEE BROWN: Well,
I mean, we make
time for whatever
is important, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
OK, good.
RENEE BROWN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RENEE BROWN: [LAUGHS]
No, I mean, time
management, it's funny.
We can get as much
done as we prioritize.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I guess there's something
to be said for if somebody
is in one of the
companies that you
work at that's in an ERG at
Google or TIAA or wherever.
Then it's almost that
person is, I guess, already
in a position of more
privilege than someone else
because they do have
a seat at the table.
So how do you advocate
for those people,
whether they're in the queer
community or people of color
or really any of these
intersectional groups
who don't have that
seat at the table?
When we look out at
our ERGs, they're
not there because for various
reasons in our society,
they haven't been
afforded that opportunity
to even be here, not having the
access to the social capital,
the educational capital, to
even get somewhere like here,
to have that voice.
How do you advocate for those
people that are basically
outside of the system?
RENEE BROWN: That's
a great question.
I don't know if I have
an answer for that one.
I would love to.
Can you help me figure it out?
AUDIENCE: I'll try.
RENEE BROWN: That'd be awesome.
Yeah.
But no, I agree with you.
As our society has spread
from the haves and have nots,
it's even more of
an issue, where
being able to figure out how
to get people out of situations
where they feel completely
without any power to change
anything is very hard.
So thank you for the
question, but I--
yeah.
I don't have an answer.
AUDIENCE: Appreciate the honest
answer because I don't know
if anyone does have the answer.
I guess we have to work on that.
RENEE BROWN: Yeah.
That's what we're thinking the
next generation is going to do.
Because the next generation
is always smarter
than the last one.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: I have
one more question.
So I feel like just
hearing you speak,
you have this amazing
confidence about your identity
and sort of your role.
And you talked about
sort of what made
you come out in the workplace.
But I guess my question
is more, have you
always had that confidence or
has it developed over time,
especially, I guess, along
with how general perceptions
of LGBTQ people have changed?
RENEE BROWN: Yeah.
That's a good question.
I mean, I think I've always
enjoyed being a leader
and have had some level
of confidence, but not
with myself, personally.
I was probably 26
before I really
was comfortable with myself.
And I think that whole
process of coming out
and talking to people and
being honest with people.
Because for so long, I wasn't
fully honest with people.
And yeah, just a funny
story, when I was pregnant
and I'd walk into rooms--
I had this job where I had to
meet with all kinds of people.
And when you're
obviously pregnant,
it's the same
question every time.
It's like, oh, Renee,
you're pregnant.
Congratulations.
I didn't know you were married.
And I'd say, well,
I'm not married.
And they would be like,
OK, what do I say now?
They were like, oh,
she's just a slut.
[LAUGHTER]
No.
And then I would just start
talking and helping them
understand the whole story.
But I had to do that over and
over and over and over again.
And if I didn't
have to do that, I
don't think I would have
gotten as comfortable
as quickly because it was
awkward and all of that stuff.
And then it gave me a platform.
And so anyway, it
was almost like not
being a straight person
is not a good thing.
It's not something
you'd put on your resume
or that your parents
are proud of.
And so it takes a lot of
years before you're like,
OK, this is me.
It's who I am.
I'm doing cool stuff.
And I'm good with myself.
So I think it takes actually
being comfortable with yourself
and getting through all that.
And some people never are.
Or people around them don't
let them be comfortable
with themselves.
But thank you for the question.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
I don't know if we had
any other questions
in the room or
questions from the Dory
that maybe we didn't
cover off yet.
RENEE BROWN: The Dory.
AUDIENCE: I can ask
about the [INAUDIBLE]..
SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
that would be great.
RENEE BROWN: Uh oh.
AUDIENCE: So I think the two
that we didn't really touch
on-- because we already
touched on what you would say
to someone--
RENEE BROWN: Advice.
AUDIENCE: --younger
in your career.
And I think you have
broached this a little bit.
But for sort of
the next generation
of folks who are identified
as queer, which issues do
you see as highest
priority in the workplace?
RENEE BROWN:
Education is probably
the top one because there's
so much confusion around,
well, what does that
mean if somebody says,
I'd like to be referred
to as they for somebody
who's a baby boomer.
And they're like, what in
the hell are you doing?
What's going on with
the whole pronoun thing?
And how do we
educate in a way that
helps people not feel like this
is some sort of change that
isn't needed.
And so I think that dialogue
across a very different
perspective is important
for the next generation.
I mean, how do you explain a lot
of the continuums people are on
related to gender and
explain it in a way that
doesn't completely freak people
out to where they shut down?
I think that's the biggest
challenge in this space
because it is change to
some fundamental pieces
that particularly the
boomer and older generations
have held as capital T truth.
And our next generation
is questioning
all of that capital T truth.
And I like that.
I think it's awesome.
So I would just try to
say, how do we educate
in a way that's meaningful?
And I actually have some friends
working on a concept that
could really help with that.
And it's called identiversity.
And it helps understand
all the elements
of gender, sexual
orientation, expression,
because all of those things
can be confusing if you don't
know how to think about them.
And so I'm working with
them to get that out
into different workplaces
to help explain and get
into gender fluidity isn't
something to be scared of
and all of that.
But we need to figure out how
to educate, would be my answer.
AUDIENCE: It's kind of tall.
I'm wondering-- it's a
lot of responsibility,
like you said, to educate
people to take moments and think
about what's a
teachable moment, what's
an appropriate moment
when you hold back.
What's a question that you
wish people would ask you
more often that would enable you
a platform that you could speak
about something that people
are uncomfortable to ask you,
either professionally
or related to LGBTQ?
RENEE BROWN: Yeah.
I think differences in
family is one of the ones
that I find
interesting because we
didn't know starting a family
what might be different.
And come to find
out, it's really not.
Because when you have a
teething baby-- somebody in here
has a teething baby, I
remember talking-- yes.
Doesn't matter if
you're straight, gay,
anywhere on the continuum,
it's still a teething baby,
and to be able to have people
that you can come together
with and ask help for.
So that whole
family piece is one.
But I've had some people ask
some pretty crazy questions.
And so there's always
interest in conception.
It's like, you wouldn't
ask that of anybody else.
So there's some extremes people
go to around different things.
I don't know if there's
ever been a question people
aren't asking enough about.
But yeah.
Yeah.
But the whole family piece
is probably important.
And definition of families
have changed so substantially
in our society, where
having an LGBT family, that
was our experience
in the childbirth.
We thought people might
be weird at the hospital,
and this was back in 2003.
And it was quite the opposite.
All the nurses were
like, we're just so
happy more than
one parent is here.
Because they have a
lot of people coming
in who are single parents
going into a situation
that's going to be really tough.
And so they're
like, we don't care
what the makeup of
the family is, as long
as there's more people
to help the child, which
I found fascinating.
It was real interesting
learning for me there.
Yeah.
Yeah, and I'm also
raising a straight ally.
So I hope I do a
good job with that.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
Well, thank you again so
much for your time today,
for being so open, and sharing
all of your stories with us--
and your thoughts.
[APPLAUSE]